[Applause]
as an 8th grader she played out varsity
and he's the second game of the year she
went 8 for 9 from three essentially won
the game for us at that point people
were saying this is probably the best
player in the state right now I started
taking that seriously when I was like 5
years old I played all the sports like
soccer baseball softball but basketball
is just so nice about to me and when I
was best at so I just continued that
back she wants to make everybody around
her better players she's a leader by
example in terms of how hard she works
she's just got it like I think it was
like maybe two summers ago I had like
8,000 followers and I was like I can't
wait to get to 10k like I want the K
next to my name but now I have like
three hundred and thirty seven thousand
followers and verified checkmark Kyrie
is my favorite player and like when I
think I was here at the high school and
i refresh my page and I said Carrie
started following I refreshed it like 50
more times just to make sure it was real
if 41 guards you this is how I
anticipate her garden you just soft look
at she stepping back she just doesn't
want to get meat off the dribble meaning
that we should be able to put her in a
ball screen pretty easily
hey 24 points and then they hate 1022 in
like 18 average
she never starts a trash talk if you
talk to her she's gonna talk back and so
this girl I don't know why but she
decided to talk trash to Paige our point
guy was doubling down the floor and
Peggy's on the way she said I might have
come off the screen I'm either gonna hit
the three of your face I'm gonna past
annachi when she comes off the screen
hey she comes out this greasy hit to
right her face you do what I tell you
like it's so funny like to see her you
like be able to back up for talking
since I've committed I've just had a lot
of weight off my shoulders and I've
really just try to enjoy it and spend
the last year with my girls as fun as I
could but I try not to think about
leaving my brother and my family my
teammates and my coaches because every
time I do I start to cry so I'm just
trying to enjoy it here for Yahoo that's
like my best friend my name is Drew and
I'm pages younger Berger and Paige gets
home from practice it's like hey drew
and they give each other a big hug and
they like to hang out you know before
every game there do their handshake or
you know if drew isn't at a game for
some reason or something Paige's kind of
freaks out a little bit like where's
drew bison trivia
[Music]
yeah we have a lot of goals we want the
section championship state championship
and if we get the opportunity we want to
go to Geico Nationals so that would mean
you have to go undefeated again we went
undefeated last year so yeah we have
pretty big goals
I think what's special about pages are
passing she's not the biggest she's got
the strongest not the fastest but what
she is is she's just so innate about her
game
give me another classroom page it's like
at first I was younger I struggle with
that like it's kind of frustrating cuz
it's like she's up in the middle of her
jump shot and then she just Chuck's a -
you don't like what like suit the ball
like her best fan or just shoot it I
always ask about my assists and my
turnovers like this is such a normal
ratio that's what I'm worried about
at the end of games like we have a coach
that keep stats and I always ask him
after the game what that looks like our
coach would be like on film like shoot
the ball she's like okay I bet you look
at us but I'm gonna keep it to you she
could score on any place she wants to
every possession but she choose to like
make her teammates better - I'm not
really like a big individual accolades
have a person I've always just cared
about winning and being the best
teammate my goal for myself is just
enjoy my senior year yeah being a girl
dad is is amazing I would still remember
Paige and I were sitting on the couch
when she was probably probably about
Drew's age probably around 7 and we were
watching Kobe play I can't remember if I
said it over there notes were sitting me
like man Kobe Bryant is so clutch and
she's like dad what does clutch mean so
that was a tough day for both of us seen
the love and passion that Gigi and Kobe
shared together um really hit home I was
gonna meet them this summer he really
likes you pond and he's worked out with
a lot of the UConn girls so I was gonna
go out there this summer and do that
Mama mentality means living life with no
fear it's not caring how many doubters
no not caring how many times you have to
do something and when I'm do it right
[Applause]
I think the heckling thing is kind of
fun like it makes the game fun I just
think as part of the game I mean people
are projecting her to you know play for
UConn since she was in like third or
fourth grade and then you know through
the years they just been extremely good
about developing a relationship with her
that's probably the biggest reason
there's no other head coach that's come
to as many games as coach Geno has what
makes you kind of great fit for anyone
as coach Auriemma he's that good getting
under the wing of coach you know I mean
I think he's the greatest coach of all
time and he just knows so much about the
game and I I think when I go there he's
gonna maximize my talents and get the
best out of me she has definitely things
that she wants to improve on to help the
grace in her game to the to the next
level and he feels that I think they all
feel that that's the best place for her
to really be pushed I say my motivation
is just knowing that I'm not at my full
potential yet and I'm just in high
school and I want to keep going in
college and the pros and I want to just
keep playing basketball I keep getting
better and never get complacent with
where I'm at right now
I'll see you guys thank you
[Music]